FOR EACH OF THE NOMINEES FOR
BEST PRODUCTION DESIGN,
IT WAS A DREAM AND JOURNEY
THAT WASN'T ALWAYS CLEAR.
GROWING UP, KATHY LUCAS LOVED
MOVIES BUT COULDN'T QUITE
FIGURE OUT WHERE SHE
FIT INTO MAKING THEM.
AS A YOUNG ARCHITECTURE
STUDENT, NATHAN CROWLEY
HAD NO IDEA HE COULD EVER
BE A PART OF THE FILM INDUSTRY.
BUT TONIGHT, THEY ARE BOTH
NOMINATED FOR "TENET."
DONALD GRAHAM BURT SPENT THE
EARLY PART OF HIS CAREER
SWEEPING FLOORS AS
AN ON-SET JANITOR.
JAN PASCALE WAS A
PUPPET MASTER ON
"MR. ROGER'S NEIGHBORHOOD."
WE RECOGNIZE THEIR INCREDIBLE
WORK TONIGHT ON "MANK."
AND AS FATE WOULD HAVE IT, JAN
PASCALE WOULD LATER HIRE
MARK RICKER AS AN INTERN, WHICH
PUT HIM ON THE ROAD TO MAKING
"MA RAINEY'S BLACK BOTTOM" ALONGSIDE
BRILLIANT SET DECORATORS
DIANA STOUGHTON AND
KAREN O'HARA.
NOW, I WONDER, MARK
WERE YOU THINKING ABOUT ANYTHING
WHEN YOU WERE GETTING JAN'S COFFEE?
I MEAN, LIKE, DID YOU
SEE THAT COMING?
JUST A THOUGHT.
PETER FRANCIS TRAINED FOR MANY
YEARS AS A LANDSCAPE ARCHITECT.
CATHY FEATHERSTONE COULDN'T STOP
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO CONSTRUCT
ONE-EYED WILLY'S SHIP AFTER
WATCHING "THE GOONIES" AS A KID,
SO SHE STARTED BUILDING SETS AND
DESIGNING COSTUMES FOR SCHOOL
PLAYS JUST BEFORE SHE TEAMED UP
WITH PETER ON "THE FATHER."
AND FINALLY, DAVID CRANK LANDED
IN MOTION PICTURE DESIGN
AFTER WORKING IN THEATER
FOR TEN YEARS.
ELIZABETH KEENAN WORKED IN
ADVERTISING FOR 15 YEARS BEFORE
HOPPING ON A PLANE TO THE CZECH
REPUBLIC TO SECURE HER
FIRST SET DECORATING JOB.
THEY ARE BOTH NOMINATED TONIGHT
FOR "NEWS OF THE WORLD."
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
"MANK"
DONALD GRAHAM BURT,
PRODUCTION DESIGN
AND JAN PASCALE,
SET DECORATION
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
IT’S A LONG WAY DOWN HERE.
FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU TO
DAVID FINCHER, CEÁN CHAFFIN
AND DON BURT FOR TRUSTING
ME WITH THIS AMAZING PROJECT.
I’M JUST, IT WAS SUCH AN HONOR
TO WORK WITH SUCH AN
AMAZING GROUP OF PEOPLE.
THANK YOU TO MY CREW WHO
WORKED THEIR TAILS OFF ON THIS,
JUST TO MAKE IT RIGHT.
AND YOU KNOW, WHEN I WAS YOUNG,
I NEVER REALIZED THAT
THIS WAS A CAREER THAT WAS
EVEN A POSSIBILITY.
THERE WERE SO MANY PEOPLE
THAT HELPED ME ALONG
THE WAY AND GUIDED ME
AND I’M SO GRATEFUL TO
ALL OF THEM AND ESPECIALLY
TO MY WIFE LOUISE,
WHO INSPIRES ME EVERY DAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.